where did the virus behind copen19 come
from
it's a question that's dogged
researchers since the early days of the
pandemic
most maintain it jumped from bats to
humans in a chinese market
some claim it could have other origins
in particular a breakout from a lab
working with viruses
getting answers hasn't been easy
china has been guarded and scientists
warned that the window to finding
kovit's true origin
is closing fast
it's a debate that has turned highly
political at times threatening to
overshadow management of the pandemic
itself from some public statements
solving the puzzle is still critical
determining the origin of sars cove 2
could help stop future pandemics
before they start
[Music]
well a new u.s intelligence report also
fails to settle on an origin theory but
it does give a small peek into the
ongoing debate
hello and welcome to deutsche fell's
cove 19 show i'm stephen beardsley in
berlin
an unclassified summary of that report
says outright that it's unlikely the
virus was developed as a biological
weapon or that chinese officials even
knew about the virus
most intelligence agencies in the u.s
still think it was a transmission that
occurred outside of the lab but the
report doesn't dismiss the lab accident
theory saying one agency concluded that
account was more probable while two
other agencies said they couldn't reject
the idea
the report said more evidence is needed
in particular early clinical samples of
the virus but that appears unlikely to
happen and it means the debate over
origin will continue
the wuhan institute of virology one of
china's leading coronavirus research
facilities several staff here reportedly
fell ill with influenza-like symptoms
weeks before the first known outbreak of
covert 19 in the same city but in early
2021 a world health organization
fact-finding team dismissed the idea
that the virus could have leaked from a
laboratory the findings suggest that the
laboratory
incident
hypothesis
is
extremely unlikely
and
to explain the introduction of the virus
into the human population
instead the who team concluded covert 19
most likely originated in bats and was
passed to humans via another animal
but some weren't convinced a group of
volunteer researchers called drastic dug
into the data drastic team members say
they found documents showing the wuhan
institute was collecting and storing bat
viruses including the closest known
relative to covert 19. and that
scientists here were experimenting to
make viruses more infectious while using
inadequate safety standards
we know uh from all of the records from
the nih grant applications from papers
published by the wuhan institute of
virology experts that they were engaged
in aggressive research and aggressive
work that was making scary pathogenic
viruses scarier
with suspicion mounting in may u.s
president joe biden ordered a new
investigation into the wuhan lab leak
theory
china rejects the claim and points the
finger at the u.s
the us in order to shift responsibility
for its poor covet 19 response and
achieve the political motive of smearing
and suppressing other countries has
pursued politicization and
stigmatization and used origin tracing
as a tool
just like the virus debate over covert
19's origins continues to mutate and
proliferate
now one thing about the virus origin is
clear it came from an animal and that
leap from animal to human appears to be
happening more frequently ebola zika
swine flu all familiar viruses in recent
years all originating from animal
species either domesticated or wild
the common thread is the increasingly
thin separation between animal habitat
and humans
something that environmental scientists
say is only getting worse as important
ecosystems disappear
navin kumar aurora is dean of the
department of environmental sciences at
baba saheb beam row on bedcare
university in look now india naveen
welcome to the show what do you make of
this origins debate if i can ask you up
front
yeah you see this origin debate will go
on but the thing is that 70 percent of
the viruses or even other microorganisms
which are pathogens are coming are
zoonotic in nature this is the report of
world health organization so most
probably this virus is also this is the
most accepted theory that this virus has
also jumped from
the animals the wild animals to the
humans
can we definitively say that this animal
to human jump is happening more
frequently
yes it is happening because you know
the human animal conflicts are
increasing
and
we are also the bush meat trade
the unorganized livestock sector
throughout the world these all are the
reasons apart from deforestation and
fragmentation of habitats climate change
all these are reasons which are causing
more
interactions of wild animals with humans
and the chances are increasing
what can we really do to prevent future
pandemics if habitat loss and climate
change for example are going to drive
future infectious diseases it seems like
we're just going to have to live with
this
yes we have to go for environmental
sustainability
sustainable development goals were
announced in 2015
but
as per the secretary general of united
nations we are not going to achieve
those targets by 2030 for the stipulated
time for the for achieving the
sustainable development goals the way
things are moving the way temperature is
increasing of our planet we can see the
disasters the
natural disasters this one is a
biological disaster so these disasters
are going to increase if we do not mend
our waste if we do not go for
environmental sustainability if we do
not
make our ecosystems robust our
biodiversity robust
you mentioned there naveen the
sustainable development goals of the un
do you think that politicians and the
public understand this idea of the
animal to human leap
thanks to what's happened with covet is
this something that now is this a
message that they've gotten
i present you know the population the
general public
is more concerned about the virus how to
save themselves rather than
focusing on how the how the breach means
how the virus has transmitted from
animals to humans how these are zoonotic
microorganisms which are causing havoc
so the focus at present of the
governments and of the general public is
rather than
on the survival
rather than on how to save themselves
in rather than to save the environment
yes there are reports there are news
there are researches which show that
environmental sustainability is much
more important so
uh
we have to wait and see once this virus
subsides once this pandemic is gone or
subsides into a regular virus then we
have to wait and see that how the public
reaction will be at present we are
saying that environment is making a
comeback and all those type of things
but
it has to be a sustainable thing means
it has to sustain for several years if
you want to
get reality into the environmental
sustainability
in the near term naveen is this changing
the way at least that we look for
viruses
yes uh yes it is changing uh means we
have to look for
the
surveillance has to be better we have to
look for how these viruses arrive into
the human ecosystem into the human
population
we have to be more vigilant we have to
be vigilant about the mutants what i
want to say suggest here is we have to
tackle the environmental pandemic
rather than this forward 19. this we we
will conquer covet 19 one day or other
but we have to tackle the environmental
pandemic which is raging since last
several decades all right we'll have to
leave it there davine kumar aurora with
baba saheb beam row on bedcar university
in look now india thank you so much
thank you thank you
it's time now for one of your questions
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
[Music]
will vaccine shortages and some
countries create new variants
another million dollar question where
where yes is a possible or or maybe even
a likely answer but not a certain one um
that's because sars kobe 2's genome
mutates all the time during replication
but only very rarely
do those mutations come together in
really dangerous ways in new variants
that have clear advantages over earlier
incarnations of the virus don't forget
there have been well over 200 million
confirmed cases of the disease so far
worldwide and healthcare authorities
think many many more
have gone unrecorded
yet the who has still only identified
four variants of concern and and four
variants of interest
the virus has therefore shown that it
can change for the worse for example by
becoming a lot more transmissible like
the delta variant
and it certainly has the potential to
evolve in even more worrisome directions
but but based on what we've seen so far
a lot of experts don't expect that to
happen really suddenly
but what should be clear is that the the
even more worrisome scenario becomes
more likely as more people are infected
to some extent it's a numbers game and
the more possibilities we give the virus
to replicate the higher the chances that
it will eventually mutate into a
pathogen that for instance
is much better at evading immune
responses in people who've been
vaccinated or people who've recovered
the best way to keep that from happening
is to vaccinate as many people as
possible as widely as possible because
the evidence indicates that even if they
get covet 19 anyway
vaccinated people are less infectious
than unvaccinated people which means
vaccinations can help stop transmission
chains which is the point
so so i wouldn't say that that vaccine
shortages in some countries will
directly create
new variants but but they do provide a
setting
where new variants are more likely to
arise
[Music]